oh boy are we getting in the thick of it
or what
oh my goodness welcome back we're on
episode four of making this rpg and
things are about to get really
interesting
ah okay a little little four four
warning for talk for play whatever you
want to call it
uh
all right so uh episode twos people left
some comments and i said i would address
them in episode four and i am doing that
and uh
this has taken me two shots i did a full
recording of this once
and scrapped it
so uh yeah i just wasn't happy with it i
thought it would be more confusing
because
it's long story but i am going to put
that outtake episode up on patreon and
on the youtube members so
you can see it if you want if you're
supporting the channel and you want to
see some outtakes and some blunders or
whatever it's actually got some decent
lessons in there c plus plus y and if
you ask me
but
uh overall we're scrapping what i did
there so this is the real episode for
now i took some time
quite a bit of time and researched and
redid and reworked and came up with the
best solution i could for our case and i
also learned quite a few things along
the way so i just really want to thank
you guys for leaving comments and even
leaving criticism i really really
appreciate you i think at some point
here near the end of this series or
after we've been going for a while i'm
going to do a like a super big giveaway
and i'm going to enter in everyone
that's left a helpful comment uh as far
as that i
i don't want to make that too
uh
formally stead set in stone but i want
to do something to give back to the
people that are working to make sure
that this is a
like a proper
lesson and not letting let me just go
off into the void with my craziness or
whatever you know
all right so with that out of the way we
are going to
delegate
these character classes away because
what we want to do and i have here in
the main and i'll show you the code
we're going to walk through all the code
and we'll walk through what you need to
change and all that
to get it to this state as well from
where we last left off
uh so yeah and by the time episode two
released episode three had already been
recording that's why i said i'd address
everything in episode four
and
uh oh geez i guess there's a few more
things i want to say so i i think i'm
going to space these episodes out a
little bit i was releasing them as
quickly as i could
all right very good just turn my phone
off it's that time of day when it's just
going to start beeping every two seconds
because apparently this is the time to
send emails uh
where was i get sidetracked all right so
yeah we want to basically what we want
to do is we want to be able to say hey
let's make a player character and we'll
give it whatever type we want
is it a rogue okay it's a rogue you hit
play it does all the rogue stuff is it a
warrior
cool then just instantiate it as a
warrior does all the warrior stuff so we
just want to delegate and forward
everything properly that way this is
easily extensible in the future if we
want a new add a new class or later like
berserker we'll be able to pop that in
easily as we see but this makes it easy
i think and this is a pretty good
long-term method that's gonna that's a
little more boilerplate as you'll see
but we're gonna walk through it all and
you're gonna learn some stuff about
delegation inheritance composition over
inheritance or or something to that
effect which we're going to talk about
as well so there's going to be a lot of
that sort of talk and some of it's my
opinion some of it's more set in stone
some of it's still up for discussion as
we're going to review as well so let's
do a little reviewing of this whole
composition over inheritance and oop
class design and which class type is
best which way of doing things best
let's just talk about a little bit help
you get an understanding i'll leave
links to all these articles down below
okay so the first thing i think is
really worth looking at is the wikipedia
page on this if you just type in
composition over inheritance one of the
first links is
this page here and it's a good read it's
well worth reading and it's got some
important lessons in it
now this is kind of language agnostic
and different languages handle this in
different ways
that being said we are sticking to the c
plus plus
theory of it the best we can but also we
do
just have to make some design decisions
in our program and there isn't
necessarily a hard and fast rule that
applies perfectly and you'll find that
happens a lot when you're programming
and another thing i want to say i keep
interjecting with things that i thought
of randomly throughout the night and
such
this is often the point where things get
a little more complicated in your
software or in your program or and if
it's a hobby program this is where a lot
of people stop i'll even say up to 90
percent like 9 out of 10 people at this
point in writing a piece of software
will quit
and
that's the important thing
push through
don't be a quitter if it's important to
you find a way to keep going so that's
what i want to say on that subject i
think that's the important lesson you
see a lot of people dive into something
all going hoe ready to go they run into
some trouble and they just quit and give
up and that might be understandable in
some cases but if it's important you
find a way to keep going because i felt
that i felt the urge it like came down
over me and was like hey this is you're
in over your head this is getting really
complicated maybe you should just call
it quits and i'm and you know that was
just like an internal dialogue and uh
the real me was like what are you
kidding no we're not quitting this is an
opportunity here this is this is the
moment that's going to be the most
important of the series probably so
keep that in mind when you're running
into trouble like that it is often the
most important defining moment of your
piece of software of whatever you're
doing
so embrace the trouble
and think on it take a day off if you
need to take a walk all that sort of
stuff it
it means
a lot
and leave your inspirational quotes down
below all right so what is composition
over inheritance
basically there's a few rules here and
there's uh some these are not hard and
fast rules these are kind of theoretical
rules
if you will and kind of
guidance rules there's a has a and it is
a type thing
so if you're talking about some
particular thing like let's just go with
their example here they have a duck
a duck
uh what does the duck have
and what is a duck and there's stuff
like that so example for example we have
a mallard duck a mallard duck it is a
duck so it should inherit
from duck because it is a duck a duck is
also an animal or a bird so it should
inherit from bird if they have that
but what does it have
it has wings and can fly
so since it has that but it you can't
say it is a fly that doesn't really make
sense
it
it it has the composition of some fly
behavior
inside of it rather than heritaging so
if it is a something you you usually
want to inherit if it has a something
you usually want to compose that within
it so you can design like this fly
behavior as a struct or something
and just use it as necessary within
maybe many
different classes or wherever needed
because a lot of different things can
fly
that aren't necessarily
ducks so i hope that makes sense we'll
get into it a little more we'll talk
about this a little more
but let's go down here
a little bit and just talk about this a
little bit so we can kind of get a base
understanding of where we're going with
this
all right i like this episode i like
this uh
example here
so we have this pure virtual function
of a
collision
delegate hope i'm saying that right
and it just takes some objects uh you
don't really need to worry about exactly
what it does but just has a pure virtual
thing it's called a delegate so this is
the one we want to work off of
so they in their case here they have a
solid and not solid object of course the
not solid one
they're going to override this collide
and have it probably do nothing because
it'll just you know everything will go
through it it's not solid
and they also have a solid version where
it's actually going to check for
colliders and do stuff so what you'll
see here
is uh so what do you do with this
not solid and solid what you do is you
make yet another class
that has a pointer to a collision
delegate and you can instantiate it
using some polymorphism power as not
solid or solid as we'll see down below
here so we have this object
and privately it has a collision
delegate that's just a pointer so it's
started as how does null pointing to
nothing but when you construct this
object
you got to pass it
whatever you're turning it into so here
on this constructor here they could pass
a
new not solid or a new solid
and it'll turn
that into what it is
and then here when they go to collide
it'll call the proper collider it'll
either be calling the collider for solid
or not solid
and work properly from there so that's
basically what we're talking about when
we mean these delegates so then going
forward into the actual code where they
would
write this
they have a say a player who is an
object and they're going to instantiate
it with some features uh
we're looking at this solid one they're
putting in a new solid so the player is
going to collide and here we have a
smoke one that they're making an example
of and it is not solid so it is not
going to collide
and they did essentially the same thing
for visible and movable and like a not
visible visible but essentially the same
case just another example
so that's that's kind of the the big
thing
and uh yeah this is somewhat language
agnostic most languages have some way of
doing this so you might have to look it
up for your language if you're following
along in a different one
but i'm going to leave it at that i'm
going to leave a link down in this
article highly worth studying if you
don't understand this fully
and i would almost even say at this
point don't worry too much about
understanding it fully just get the gist
of it here
and get some practice with it and it'll
click more and more the more you use it
okay and i actually found some good
discussion on the subject over on stack
overflow
uh this one i thought was pretty good
so let's have a gander at what they were
talking about here super old uh asked 13
years ago yes stack overflow used to be
pretty good people used to have pretty
good discussions on here uh it's pretty
rare to find these days but i felt like
this was pretty relevant to what we were
doing someone basically just asked which
design is better all right they have a
user an employee an employee
inherits from user
and uh
yeah just basically something like that
they were just trying to figure out
the basically the same thing we're
trying to figure out
here
and then they have another version here
where they have an employee that has a
user
as a field here
rather than inheriting from it
and remember that also does too so just
kind of a kind of the same thing we're
running into and some people had some
good answers here and of course we
talked about there is a and it has a
relationship which we already kind of
talked about and
this is a good general rule but
something something really important is
said here that i think gets overlooked
uh
human languages are vegan and precise
programming languages can't afford to be
so while you can kind of use this as a
you can say it in english and get an
understanding of maybe how you should
structure it
just because it makes sense in english
doesn't necessarily mean that's how you
should be doing it so there's some other
things we need to think about is a it
has a is a good general rule to follow
and probably 99 percent of time or 95 or
something most of the time it will
work for making sense
but sometimes
it won't so
the stuff we were doing in episode two
was somewhat technically correct like it
would work
but it depends how we're going to reason
about
these variables and classes in the long
run
also which we will get into in a little
bit
okay someone says i don't like either
one what happens when someone is both a
member and an employee right yep so
we're running in some trouble and here's
here's another comment that i thought
was really good okay so we have the is a
and as has a question good
if it is a user use inheritance if it
has
user information use composition okay
there's that but also some a couple
other just really important questions uh
if there's virtual functions involved
use inheritance all right so this is
another thing to think about there's
virtual functions involved use
inheritance which we do see some in ours
so
but we'll get to that
and can it have multiple instances
of
of the thing if so
use composition so if it can have
multiple instances of something
don't use inheritance because what if it
needs to have multiple
and we could see that we can see that
some we'll get into that too because we
are going to talk about that
and it doesn't make sense
to employ
or to assign an employee object to a
user object so use inheritance so we'll
talk about that a little bit too
all right
and
yeah one of them allows polymorphic
behavior so where we want to use that
polymorphic behavior we want to be sure
to be using inheritance if we don't need
the polymorphic behavior and we might
want multiple
and it's more of a has a
then we're going to come use composition
otherwise inheritance so
cool stuff all right so let's dig into
the code and let's write it
i really hope you'll leave a like and
help support this particular series and
especially this episode because this
like i said is probably one of the more
going to be one of the more important
episodes as far as learning some of this
stuff and it's by far taking me the
longest compared to any of the others so
far
so uh yeah with that let me let me get
some stuff prepared and we're gonna
start coding
to get your code fingers ready
okay so as you can see here i made
another branch called class delegation i
did not push this branch because this is
basically one where i was just testing a
bunch of things and trying to come up
with the method that i thought worked
for our best for our case so that's one
of the things when you're writing your
own software working on something you
just got to come up with the best case
for what you're doing you're very very
rarely going to find the perfect answer
for almost anything you're doing
creatively and i think i came up with
the best one that seems to work pretty
good
so what i'm going to do is just go back
to our main branch and kick out all
these changes and we're going to just
make these changes throughout this
episode
let me just do that real quick
so
changes
we're just gonna stash all i suppose
stash all sure
and there we go we're back to our old
original version that is exactly where
we left off on episode three
all right so
uh in our main here first of all let's
go ahead and just get rid of one of
these we're only going to need one of
these really to test
and
we're no longer going to be
instantiating each class individually
we're instead going to be pulling
something like player character
and give it whatever name you want and
instantiate it as a new and then
whatever clash you want
and it should
handle it from there and we no longer
want to say cleric here uh this is just
sort of some front end so we can run the
test when it works properly but
sometimes you would do this part last
p1 we're going to have it get class name
that way
whatever class it is we'll just
automatically populate the name
correctly
and
then we can get rid of cleric there
still want a space then level and then
these are all going to be
the player p1 or whatever you named your
variable
and we'll clean this up a little more
than just that but essentially we want
to do kind of the same thing we just
want to get a little stat sheet give it
a level see make sure it's leveling up
correctly and check those base cases
there
and as you can see it's not happy right
now and we're going to have clear
character
instead
this is just uh
yeah you don't necessarily have to do
this first you can do this last if you
want but that's this is what we're
aiming for we want this to work
correctly
all right so we have all these things
we're going to condense this down and
simplify it a lot and it's going to be a
lot better
alright so first of all let's where do
we start all classes here we're not
going to use this anymore so we can
delete this all classes file
and we're just going to kind of go
through and clean up as we go
cleric
yeah we're going to
merge the cleric rogue wizard warrior
we're going to merge all of this
into
one file right now we have a level
system
in this level system
we're just going to change this this
level system we're going to turn into
player
character
this is going to be our big player
character file that does and handles
everything it has all the boilerplate to
to make some nice expanding later
so this level system
is no longer going to be just level
system it's going to be player
character
delegate
so this is going to be our pure virtual
basically base class
for our players
and we're going to keep a lot of this
stuff we're going to of course rename
the constructor
and anything else we might need to
rename but for the most part it's
actually going to stay about the same
here
so every character is going to have the
ability to level up but you can see
level up is going to be pure virtual so
we cannot instantiate this player
character delegate we can only inherit
from it and that's going to be the big
point here so let's go ahead and bring
in our classes
one at a time so let's take this cleric
and we're just going to copy all this
go down into here
and paste it down below there's our
cleric we can now get rid of our cleric
file
and we'll fix this up let's go one at a
time here
uh let's see here
all right so now we have cleric
inheriting from stuff of course we want
level system right um
or do we that's kind of a question here
yeah what should we do player character
delegate do we want stat block
uh we're going to do stack lock and hp
differently so we're actually going to
delete those all we want to inherit from
as a character class is player character
delegate per character delegate should
be able to handle as many things as
possible and now we need to make some
design decisions is a player character a
hit point
or or that sort of thing no i wouldn't
say so so many different things could
have a hit point so we're going to
rework the hit points and call it
something different we're no longer
going to inherit we're rather going to
use composition there
is a player character a stat block
i'm gonna go with yes on this now this
is debatable of course but you hear this
a lot you hear this a lot in games have
you ever heard that uh
so and so character is just a stat stick
because they've got huge stats i i think
you can call characters stat sticks or
stat blocks so we are going to inherit
from this i think it makes sense in our
case and also
uh as we're looking talking about those
rules we mentioned a little earlier you
never want more than one stat block only
one stat block and you always have a
stat block so in this case
i think it makes sense
that we inherit
stack block
and we're gonna of course need to
include stat block
and that's pretty good and of course
later when we make like monsters and
npcs and stuff they're also going to use
the stat block too
because yeah they're going to be stat
sticks too sometimes so i yeah this one
i think it makes sense to inherit from
just because you never have more than
one
there might be some cases later for
having more than one stat block if you
have
some sort of weird special ability but
that's not that's way too complicated
for this base stuff
i
we're just going with the design
decision of yeah
a player character is a stat block
that makes sense but you can't say
necessarily they're an hp block so what
are we gonna do with hp uh it's hit
points now all hit points are is
basically
you know something that has a max and it
has a tracker of where it's currently at
that is not unique to hit points i don't
think it actually makes a whole lot of
sense to call this hit points so we're
going to call it something else we're
going to call this a point well so as a
well is like a well of water or
something like that and it has a
fullness level of course it can get to
max or it can get to minimum can't go
negative
and it can't go above the max
so point well and what this means
is uh we can use this for a lot of
different things we can use this for
durability we could use this for
currency we could use this for mana we
could use this for energy we could use
this for rage
it's all essentially the same thing it's
a point well that's i'm just calling it
a point well because i don't know what
better to call it so we might have
multiple of these thus we're going to
use composition on the point well
and we're just going to go ahead and
rename all these point well
and then just change these so we have
like set max hp we're just going to
change that to set max
uh i need to rename more of these
variables but i'll do that later we have
a get max
we have a get current
let's take damage we're just going to
change to reduce
and this heal we're going to change to
increase
the logic is still going to say stay
approximately the same
and uh yeah that should be pretty good
you know there's one bit of logic i kind
of forgot to put in here and that's
if your current hp goes negative what
happens then
well since we're using unsigned integers
what's going to happen is it's going to
change to a giant number
so we have this current hp
minus equals damage
well actually i think we have this
handled pretty well because if the
damage is greater than the current hp
then it's just going to set it to zero
so yeah actually we have the case
handled i was just thinking
i was thinking here we needed another
case in case this wrapped it to a high
number but this initial
if statement should handle that so
yeah i think we're good there
increase looks fine
and
yeah i think everything else is probably
okay here there might be some edge cases
here and there so we could in theory do
some
uh elaborate and very thorough testing
of this point well later but we'll worry
about that a little later
if ever so hp type we're no longer going
to call this hp type we're just going to
call it well type here
so there we go well type and that's not
the best name in the world in my opinion
because
it sounds like maybe wellness or health
which that sort of makes sense i guess a
little bit but i couldn't really think
of anything i didn't really want to do
point type because point type is
there's a lot more overlap there i feel
like with sometimes you think is points
as like 3d points of an x y and z and
stuff like that so i'm going to go with
well type we could even go point well
type but we'll stick with well type
there's a lot of other variables that
need named here like this
new max hp
and you know everything that basically
says hp we just kind of want to get rid
of basically so we could go through and
do something like this
and just rename anything that says hp
to a blank
so let's just kind of take a quick look
here and make sure that
makes sense uh so we're just going to
hit the button
delete all those
and yeah that looks like it handled that
so we don't see hp we got an underscore
here which is a little awkward i guess
get that off of there
but for the most part we're okay we have
a current and a max of the well type and
yeah i think that's pretty good so in
general wait a second
something weird happened in one of these
oops
oh yeah the constructor so the
constructor is no longer hp it's going
to be
very good
got that
and yeah i think we're done with the
point well we will save that don't see
any errors there we've got some weird
line with the syntax helper but
whatever it's doing it's going to take a
minute to catch up so we will well wait
wait it's because we need to put point
12 either as well
we have two constructors one where it's
just the default constructor sets them
to one or you can specify
and it does a thing so that's fine for
now we might change that later but we're
not going to wear it by audit format
that's fine
let's close that
okay and now we get some more
interesting things of course we already
put our cleric in here in this player
character class i'm going to close down
this point well and this
stat block because i think we're
done with those for the mo i will leave
stat block open
player character we have this open twice
that shouldn't be possible
not sure how that happened okay so we
want to open our player character and
we're just going to work on this
and and go through and do what we got to
do
as we continue on so let's look at the
cleric that we pasted in here and see if
we can get this worked out now i'm also
going to do another thing as we go here
this great this growth rate on this uh
hp strength and end and base
sort of redundant to have both of them
in my opinion
because we're just making the growth
half of whatever the base is so since
that's a formula we don't necessarily
need all these variables and it's going
to clean it up a lot and that way when
we level up what we're going to end up
doing
is just uh
we're going to grow it by whatever
the
base is
but we're going to have it
so we're going to divide by a float
whatever that ends up being we're going
to cast back into
uh hp type
or well type now
and up here we need to be sure to
include
well type or point well rather
point well
the way we get everything from that new
hp pool thing
and we're going to have to clean this up
a little bit too hp is no longer going
to be constructed like that
stat lock also not going to be
constructed the same either
so we'll get rid of that and we're going
to basically redo these constructors but
i just want to get the one sorted out
for the cleric and then we can propagate
that down to the rest
and uh yeah we should be able to go
pretty well from there okay so the level
up we're basically going to call set
max it says hp here
but we really just want to set max on
uh okay that point well so the the point
well
for hp
is going to be in our player character
delegate i think we're just going to pop
it in here as a public we're going to
make this a unique pointer
unique pointer to a point well
called hb
because you only have one and we want
the auto handle since we're using a
unique pointer here we're going to
include
memory
i guess we don't necessarily have to
make this a unique pointer
here but
i feel like
i had some reason for it when i was
constructing all this
and i think it's actually i think i
explain it
in that last episode that i'm not going
to post
if it comes to mind i'll say it again
but it's not coming to mind right now
but that's the way we're going to do it
and that way later if we decide we have
mp or something we can put that in here
as well as the second one but we need to
make sure that this is not null or
uninstantiated
or whatever it may be
so it says pointwell is undefined uh why
is that let's go over back to pointwell
oh class we didn't rename the class so
we want this to be
no longer hp
wait what happened here
i thought i renamed all these
didn't we just redo this class
where'd it go
no
okay well i guess i'll redo it again
okay
and i just pop it back in there i'm not
sure why that didn't save i must have
done something wrong
but uh yeah we're essentially going to
do the same thing again just clean this
up a little bit
and instead of current and max it is
current fullness and max well
so a little tiny bit of difference in
the syntax there but essentially the
same thing
and we're going to make that c and m
again c
m
we just don't want to be saying hp
actually in here anyway so there we go
we'll just walk through this real quick
our type is now called well type and we
got to set max we got to get max we got
to get current we got a reduced current
and an increased current
uh slightly different name than i said
earlier
and we got our same constructors
up like that and like that
okay let's hit save make sure it
actually saves this time not sure if i
didn't last time and and close it is it
actually there let's reopen yeah looks
good that was really weird not sure why
that happened
but apparently i glitched out
something all right
very good so
uh we're looking at our stat block here
oops that's uh approximately the same
for now let's go back to our player
character and keep working on this where
we just left off a moment ago all right
so we were instantiating that point well
as hp
so we're getting that composed in there
i think no matter what your player
character is going to have hp but the
reason we don't necessarily want to put
like
uh like uh you know in some games the
rogue has energy uh voyager has rage
stuff like that like warcraft
we gotta decide that later but it's not
all of them so if they do have that we
will put it down in their class type
rather than in the delegate
we will compose that since it can have
more than one of these point wells
and i think that makes sense
now in this cleric here let's keep
working on the cleric and get this all
sorted out we're going to redo this
constructor
this hp
type is now well type and we got base hp
we'll keep these the same for now and we
just got some bases
so let's work on this level up real
quick here
basically we want to call
hp
set max now uh hp of course is a pointer
a new unique pointer
and we need to absolutely make sure that
it is actually getting constructed and
set up so we're going to do that in this
default constructor here we're going to
say hp
equals standard make
unique uh
point well
and it's gonna want some stuff to
construct with we're just going to leave
it blank and the that way it uses the
default constructor on the hp
which is just going to set to one and
one
yeah that's i think that's fine for now
yeah later we will use
i guess set max in the constructor
probably to set the max
uh to what it should be for the class
but yeah let's just start it as a one
one so that way if you maybe we have a
class later that's just really really
basic or something
yeah i think one and one just one hit
point starting out is fine for our
particular design all right so let's
work on this level up
we might be getting a little ahead of
ourselves let's worry about the level up
here and in just a second i'm just going
to call it out for the moment so in our
constructor what do we want to do
basically in our constructor we just
want to set up
the uh the hp
and the stats for now that's all we
really want to do
and so the way we're going to do that
here
is we're going to call the base
constructor of the player character
delegate
so it does its thing
and that's going to set current level to
1 xp to 0
your next level xp at whatever level 2
is at just get all the space stuff and
it's going to set up our hp well we want
to make sure that all gets nice and set
up and it's going to do that
and then
we want to set it to the clerics hp so
we'll go
hp
set max
and base hb
there we go and we'll also call hp
uh let's just make sure they actually
have max hit points when they get
instantiated so we're just going to
increase current and we're also just
going to increase it by base hb
and if that go ends up going one or two
over
based on the logic of increased current
it's just going to set to max
uh like so so that's just fine there so
that gets their hp sorted out for that
particular class and we also want to get
the stats sorted out for this particular
class too so we need to take a quick
look at our stat block here what does
our staff lock do by default it sets
strength and intellect to 1.
we're going to change this just a little
bit i think here i think we are going to
default it to zero
so if you don't tell it anything your
stats are just going to be
zeros which might potentially mess up
some math later but i think that's fine
we could still instantiate it with this
sort of thing
but since it's going to be default
constructed
in our
character delegate
with this public stat block i guess we
should actually have it here
like uh stat lock
and yeah let's just make these zeros
uh yeah let's do it this way
uh because we might use a stat block in
different ways okay nevermind we'll
leave this the same if you use the
default constructor you get one strength
one intellect sure fine enough
we may or may not even use that to be
honest because
we'll see we're going to use this
explicit one for now and set it to
whatever we say and we're just going to
make them zeros for player characters
because
we want to use the increase function
to set the defaults
and yeah that should work pretty well so
let's go down to our cleric and we're
just going to call
increase stats
and then we want to put base strength
and base
hint so since they start out with zero
increasing them by their base will give
you your nice defaulting start stats
it's just the way we're deciding to
design it trying to future proof it a
little bit thinking we're going to use
that stat block for maybe a lot of
different things eventually
a lot of different npcs and monsters so
this is the design we're going with for
now
so this should
be pretty well
for that default now let's talk about
our level up we want to increase our max
by half of the base
and of course we need to get whatever
the max hp is but hp is a little
different now we don't have a yeah it's
just a get max
sometimes this
um
they say not to do it in this way
necessarily but
it's going to work fine for our case and
if we need to refactor that a little
later we can't we're going to do the
same thing with increased stats we're
going to use whatever the base is
uh divide it by 2
it's going to cast to a float and then
we're going to cast it
to stat type
and i guess i can talk a little bit
about math here
and uh some order of operations so we're
going to be careful about this
uh
the innermost parentheses
will
calculate first
so we want to make sure we're not
casting
base strength the stat type then divided
by 2 because it's going to turn into a
float
and why it looks like we're casting to a
tightly by accidentally casting to a
float
so we just want to be careful about how
we do these
we want to make sure that we have our
calculations inside parentheses this is
not necessarily required there are
different ways of doing it i just think
personally it makes it a lot clearer
when you have all your operations very
specifically
defined within parentheses so example
let's go like this on this hp one and
i'll explain very quickly in case you
don't know so our innermost parentheses
is this right here it's going to do this
calculation first and it's going to cast
to a float so base hp 14 divided by 2
dot f it's going to be like a 7.0
float
and then
we're going to work out the next
parentheses which is this so
it's going to get this max hp and it's
going to add it to that float and then
it's going to cast that to well type and
that should be pretty accurate for what
we're doing there's going to be some
automatic rounding generally whatever
the automatic rounding is is if it just
casts to a type that doesn't have
decimals is it just cuts off the decimal
so basically it's an always round down
case
we might want it to always round up or
something but we can address that later
or we can apply a little
magic to make it a little more
uh player friendly
we'll say
so for example what we probably want to
do
is uh
on your stats
we probably want to just add plus 1
to this base before dividing that way
it gives us a round up so in our case
it's going to the half of the strength
is going to be
just one so you're going to get one more
strength per level up
but
if we're going to reuse this code
sometimes people have like odd strength
like three
and it's still only going to give you
one maybe even in that case we want to
give you a two this is just going to
make it round to two
if it's odd
now
so
it's just going to make it round up
rather than down in a lot of those cases
i think we'll do the same thing here
well this should be big tenth
that could cause some bugs uh
plus one u so we're just gonna round up
on those odd cases just to be a little
more user friendly
because in this case they would only
uh if we didn't have this plus one or
some kind of floor or math operation we
could of course include c math and put
that floor or something in there but
this
we'd rather have just a plus one in here
than including a whole nother header uh
for now
it's the reason i'm doing it this way
okay so this is looking pretty good i
think yeah so base int
it's gonna calculate to four and then
half that so they're going to get two
rather than the one
just some math rounding stuff and what
doesn't this like here we got two maybe
in parentheses again
so there's this one that's the strength
and then there's okay let me know the
parentheses right here
there's this one that's the end okay so
there's that level up
and the cleric is actually looking
pretty good here
so
uh yeah we're not quite ready yet we
still want our final delicate we don't
actually want to instantiate cleric by
itself rather we want to delegate
these classes so that in your main you
can call
player character so we need to make
player character we're just going to put
that way at the bottom here
we're going to make class player
character
and
in this one you're gonna see we don't
inherit anything
rather
we're going to have in here a player
character
delegate
that is a pointer
and we'll just call it pc class
or player character class
all right so that's private pal here
we'll just make it very explicit here
and click private here
and publicly what we want to do is we
want to have one constructor that's one
that takes the class so let's actually
go player character let's take this
default constructor and just make sure
it doesn't exist with delete that way
nobody tries to use that
and we want to have player character
that takes a pointer to player character
delegate
so we can use polymorphism on this bad
boy
let me make sure i'm still recording i'm
having nightmares flashbacks of last
episode where i accidentally turned the
recording off
oh okay
this episode's gonna be a little bit
longer that's fine we're actually
getting pretty close to done
uh just a few more things here
but there's been a lot of laughs and
lessons in this one so this is a pretty
important one all right player character
delegate we can name this anything i'm
just going to call pc
and what we want to do here is just say
that whatever that pc pointer we're
pointing her passing into here we're
just going to say pc class or
let's construct here pc
class
is whatever that pc is
and that should take care of it
so what's gonna happen now is when you
instantiate a player character
you gotta call some valid
class delegate
and of course you can't pass it
this
player character delegate itself because
it's pure virtual so you need some
overridden version of it to pass right
now we have a cleric that is currently
valid that's the only one we have in
here for right now so let's actually go
over to our main
and just see if this works with cleric
seems to be taking a minute to figure
out whether it's happy or not
okay it does look like we need to
make this get class name method we might
need to fix up a few other things
but overall this actually should work so
maybe we just need to
give me just a second all right let's go
back into
player character
let's make this other function here
uh we're going to use string and we're
just going to strengthen up
it class name and all this is going to
do is just return
uh
well construct a string
not a string buff
audit formatting that
uh cleric so we'll just do this for each
class we make that way we can call get
class name on it it'll automatically
construct now it doesn't know what a
string is we just have to include it
if you know a better faster way of doing
this awesome you're welcome to make a
full request
on that but
c plus plus isn't super good at
having ways of getting class names as a
string
i think there are some ways of doing it
with macros but
we're just going to simplify it and just
do this and each of them
that way we can just call
later in our code get class name
like so
and it should just work
all right so what's the problem here why
doesn't it like this
all right we're going to hit compile
compiler says
player character no such file or
directory so we just spelled it wrong
correct sure let's see in there
that works hit play yep still complains
it can basically complains that
player character doesn't have these
functions and it's right
it actually doesn't so if we look at our
player character this is kind of our
main interface one that we actually
construct we're not inheriting from
everything so it only very literally has
what we have here so basically we need
to uh delegate these out and call the
functions
that we want to call
so
we kind of need to do some code
duplication here which is a bit ugly but
for like get class name
what do we want to do right we want to
have
okay string we'll have to make this
again get class name
but rather
we don't necessarily know the name of
the class but you know what does this pc
class because
it's it's in here
so uh this pc class is always going to
have that actually you know we're doing
this a little wonky this should actually
be virtual as well so virtual
void
get
class name
equals
zero or not void string here
so you have to implement this as well
and we will do that that way we make
sure it has it for the delegate so we'll
just do the same thing here except
override
and there we go looks pretty good
so now we'll have pc class
get class name
and that is just going to
then return the
whatever type that this ends up being so
that's pretty good we're going to need
to basically do that for all these that
have an error and anything else we want
to be publicly available and we can even
rename them slightly if we want to like
this get max hp
of the player character that's actually
going to be a little different now
because
let's see what
yeah that's going to be just part of
this point well it's going to be get max
so that's that's fine but i think in our
player character delegate
we'll we'll have it
called get max hp and it's going to call
hp
get max
hope that all makes sense we're
basically going to be doing a lot of
typing here and getting this all sorted
out uh the next one is git level
uh it says it doesn't know about that
says it doesn't know about a lot of
different things here
so we just basically got to sort all
those out and then we'll add in the rest
of the classes right now we're just
getting set up with cleric
and then we can expand later so as
you'll see by the end of this and learn
that
you'll be able to very easily add more
classes which will be great for
expanding say we have an expansion that
comes out where we add a berserker we'll
show you how to do that at the end it
makes it super easy to do that sort of
thing so this is definitely
the right way to be doing this i think
for our cases so get level it's going to
return
level type get level
and it's going to once again use this
delegate bc class
get
level
and there we go so that'll forward it to
the proper
one whatever we instantiated this as now
this also kind of brings up another
thing that i wasn't thinking about
necessarily earlier and that's since we
have a pointer here
we want to also make sure we're
controlling the destruction of it so if
player
character
gets deleted
tilde in front of that
we're gonna call delete
pc class
because we need to make sure this member
goes away
if uh this class goes out of scope or
something otherwise it won't uh
and then we'll just go pc
class
equals null pointer
that should take care of that that also
gives us the option to do maybe some
cool special stuff
later like uh maybe we want to have a
respec option where you decide hey i
don't want to be a rogue anymore i'd
rather be a warrior we could call this
destructor than to instantiate as a new
warrior and then give it the levels and
then you'll be able to do all your level
ups as a warrior so it just makes stuff
like that a lot more simple
so pretty cool did i spell that wrong
yes i did a character it has a c in it
all right now let's just keep building
these functions we're just going to go
through and plug away
uh what else we got we got get current
xp which returns an xp type get
current exp
pc class and these are just going to
keep forwarding these functions
this delegation method
x
current exp
and what's the next one get xp to next
level copy that line down
to next
level
and name the same thing
some of these are not going to be named
the same thing as we'll see here
well type get
current
hb
bc
class
hp
get current so that's a little different
there since we're going to have
different wells but uh for this player
character get current hp is nice and
clear and it does what it's supposed to
do and if we add mp later we can
add the
other method
we also want to get max hp it's going to
be very similar except instead of get
current here it's going to be kit max
and we have get strength which is going
to return a stat type
get strength
you see class
now this one
has it directly
there we go same thing for intellect
anything else we need gain xp at the
void method
gain exp
ec class
and exp
and we need an amount of exp of course
so we need a exp type and outsole
and we'll just forward that amount
so they get the experience for their
class
and let's see we also need some ways to
take damage and heal so let's go ahead
and add those in
we're just going to call it take damage
in this case and that's going to take a
well type
pc
class
hp
and we have an increased current
oh we need to put a variable name in
there
just keep using amount
so increase it by whatever that amount
is and we're also going to have a heal
and heal for some amounts
oh wait this one should be the use
current my pad and this one's already
correct with increased current so there
we go we got those methods forwarded
correctly
and we can make more as needed
if we need to
but i think for now that works so let's
go ahead and hit play complains a little
bit
uh get max hp
is not a member okay but if we name it
we named it
yeah get max hp
okay what is it complaining about
player character has no member get max
hp
so
yeah it does
it's right here
what did we do wrong
okay it's capital hp so i just missed
the capitalization very
little mistake there we're going to hit
hit play here
and it complains about just a few other
things get intellect must return a value
variable
yes very true so we should be having
return
all on all of these
that are returning something
uh
kind of a no-brainer there
just uh overlooked that
boom boom
boom
now let's do it
and there we go so we instantiate our
cleric let's make sure he's all leveling
up correctly at level one zero xp
max
hp looks good strength looks good
intellect looks good okay levels up
uh it gains half the max seven more hp
up to 21 looks good strength uh one more
strength that's half the base looks good
intellect a half of three rounded up as
we intended with our
thing there is going to be
no should be two more so yep goes up to
five looks good let's just uh improve
our formatting a little bit this max hp
let's just turn this to hp
and let's say
let's do a similar thing that we did
with the level
p1 we'll do a get current hp
add a little slash here
but you know this slash gives a
character actually so
there we go so now there will have a
how much out of how much type of deal
looking thing on the hp yeah 14-21 okay
as we see we level up we don't get our
new xp added to our pool
let's go ahead and fix that real quick
uh that's just going to be in that level
up code
okay so level up code
set max hp
we just want to increase current as well
hp increase current
same number since we're doing this
calculation twice
maybe we just want to get the variable
or actually we don't
there we go let's just do this
there we go so we also increase it by
whatever we gained
which is what this calculates too
it's doing that calculation a couple
times there
and that should now
give us our new hp
there we go some games give you a full
heal when you level up we're not going
to do full heal we're just going to say
however much you gained
you're also going to heal for that much
that way you get all your new hit points
so
that's going to be the way we do it
there okay so that's all looking really
good for the cleric what about the rogue
warrior wizard and how do we avoid
typing this exact same code over and
over
that i will show you
okay so what we're going to do is just
go to each of these classes and we just
want to grab all this stuff now it's
really the same as the cleric as we
might know so we could actually
even just copy down this whole
cleric thing
like so
boom
change this to rogue
change this to
rogue you know just quick renaming here
a couple renames not a huge deal
and then
we will have
all the same stuff the bases are
different for a rogue so we really just
want to sort that out twelve three and
two
that's easy enough
twelve
three
and
two
and there we go just like that we have
added a robe class we can delete this
file we don't need it anymore
but now in our main we could say
new rogue
hit play
and it's just so easy to extend this
with no classes it's it's a beautiful
thing oh my goodness let's look at that
we got the rogue there's the base hp
strength intellect goes to level two
adds six more hit points that's correct
adds two more strength that's correct
adds one more intellect and it works it
works correctly
so as you can imagine we're just going
to do the same thing
for
the warrior and wizard and just put
their bases in there
so pretty straightforward and i want to
show you just one last little trick
before we close this all out
warrior
warrior
warrior
fix those bases eighteen four
one
four one gotta remember that because i'm
gonna type in manually
18
four
one
and
we can give it a test
warrior
and just by changing that one thing we
get everything correct says the right
type increases correctly
look at this beefcake
the best the best strength in the game
the most hit points
well
yeah we'll see how that works out i feel
like the warrior might be a little op
but we'll see
speaking of a little prelude here next
episode episode 5 we're going to be
starting to dig into
enemies in combat so we're gonna start
getting our combat system going oh boy
i'm so excited for that all right let's
get the wizard in here uh we got a
10-1-4 okay let's just
do the same copy down
change this to wizard
wizard wizard
and what was it ten one four ten
one
four
delete this class or yeah this file
rather
no we could also instantiate as a wizard
if we want
hit play make sure that looks good
uh yep i think that looks fine
10 hp
goes up we're going to lag yep okay
so wizards looking good
and now uh yeah we're mostly done but
there's one thing i want to address here
and that's
uh this level up code
and this
constructor
they're exactly the same
there's really no difference on any of
them
so we want to come up with a way where
we don't have to retype this code
because currently this is 177 lines of
code yeah we're sure we got a little bit
of redundancy here
uh
but what we can do here is we can use
the power of macros
to to handle this for us
so let's do that in the macro here
macros are something pretty important to
learn you might need to look them up
we're going to use a very very basic
method of them here but you see these a
lot code sometimes they make it
confusing
so let's let's go ahead and do a macro
you do this hash define and then you
give your macro a name uh we're going to
call this first one pc construct in all
caps
and then after this it's uh this is the
code
so there's its variable name and then
what it does currently
it's just like a blank space probably pc
construct is is
defined as nothing but we want to define
it as
this whole chunk of code here basically
everything after the class name so
we're going to hit
i just hit control x there
i'm going to go up here
and ctrl v so
paste it in now uh macros
don't understand new lines so when you
put a real new line in there it ends the
macro so we'd have to put this all in
one line but that's going to be a little
hard to read so what we're going to use
is just backslashes or new lines
to eat the new line rather to say ignore
this new line
ignore this new line or this new line or
this new line
and there we go now it's it's
essentially all one line it just doesn't
look like that in our code but now
instead of typing all that out and all
of these
we can just put pc construct right here
and that'll work and we can do that for
all of them so let's go down to our
rogue
bc construct
lawyer
pc construct
pc construct wizard and since they're
using these same named
bases
that's why we can do this
because the code is exactly the same on
all of those and we'll go ahead and hit
compile here it's going to recompile
and as you can see it still works fine
and now the level up code is also
exactly the same so we can do the same
thing with that let's go ahead and do
another define
this is of course optional but i like to
do it if there's a lot of repeating code
and we're going to put in here level
and what's it defined as
well it's going to be exactly this code
so i'm just going to cut that
and
paste it right here
and of course the anywhere there's a new
line let's put that slash
slash slash slash
and
leave the new line at the end of course
so that it actually ends the macro
okay and now anywhere where it says
level up
or this level of code we can just put
literally here just plain old level up
and it's going to paste in all this code
for us
so we'll just do that privately in each
of them whoops let's copy that level up
and let's just put it right there
level up
level up so essentially what we start to
have here
is just like a
a nice clean base template that we could
use for any new class if we ever want to
add in another class
we just use the same template rename
this keyword to whatever the new class
name is change our basis to whatever it
is
and it's going to do everything
pretty much
automatically which is extremely
extremely nice
and
maybe i'm doing something that's
that visual studio is not liking but it
looks like it's giving me some little
underlines here
and let's see what does it want to do
what is it complaining about
consider adding a hint file
i don't normally do that but it looks
like if we go to
quick actions and refactoring or hit alt
enter over it it says add macro pc
construct to new c plus plus hint file
i don't know do this if you want i guess
it seems awkward to me just because i
never do it maybe someone can explain
uh
the elaborate point of that because i
i'm gonna be honest i don't get it you
could literally just look at the macro
here right
so
i'm not sure what the point of that is
but it wants us to do it i'm not going
to do it i'm going to skip it another
thing it's doing that's a little awkward
is it's having a little trouble with the
syntax formatter like if i auto format
this for some reason it double indents
this git class name not sure why it does
that either a little weird if it's uh
resolving as this code it should
understand that this doesn't need double
indented i'm just going to put it above
the pc construct thing
in this case
just so that my auto formatter stops
being weird
so just moving all these up
for our template
so now we just have a very nice template
we could even take this a step forward
further by making another macro that
takes a name
and takes some bases
and we could just like
expand this further but i'm not going to
worry about that right now that gets a
little complicated
uh in my opinion
let's go ahead i think we want to space
on these it doesn't matter a ton but
yeah this looks really weird for c plus
plus code but basically these words are
just resolving to this code every time
and since it's exactly the same this is
a perfectly fine thing to do it's
something you can do
if you find yourself repeating the same
code but can't exactly turn it into a
function
uh this sort of thing will work often
just making it a macro instead it's
going to clean things up a lot
all right cool
now let's uh let's run this
make sure it all works
looks good still instantiating a wizard
and now
just as a quick example
berserker here let's say we add a
berserker
and they'd be very simple to do
we basically just want to take this
go like so
rename it to berserker
i'll leave the berserker in here why not
change all of that to berserker give
some base hp
uh start them out at 20.
now let's do the same as the warrior
uh
i don't know we need to make design
decisions and i i don't necessarily want
to but let's just say he has
five strengths and still one end
i don't know just another thing we could
do
and it's a berserker that should all it
should just work now now we've got all
another class with a whole new scaling
system which is some very easy to
maintain and update code so that's the
whole point of this delegation thing
compared to the way we were doing it
before just
now that this is all set up it's so easy
to maintain and update and add to and
expand
so
yeah i hope you got a lot out of this
episode hope you enjoyed i really enjoy
doing this this is really fun for me
this is probably the most fun thing in
the world this is like the only thing i
ever shut my phone off for
because i enjoy it so much so
that's uh
pretty interesting i'm going to delete
the circuit
we don't actually
it's not in our original design maybe
that's for an expansion later
but
there is one drawback in here and i
couldn't think of how to fix it and that
is that people
if they're using these classes
they could just instantiate a warrior
still
rather than using this method here
they could go
let me just comment that out you could
still go
warrior
and that's valid so i guess my question
would be how do we make this invalid to
make sure nobody does this
because we're not going to get what we
want
i guess you could still do all this
stuff
but we don't get the forwarded methods
we don't get this player character stuff
we only get
whatever's in
whatever class we implemented so we
wouldn't get this heal and take damage
we would have to use whatever we're
we're doing here which may maybe is okay
but it starts to get a bit
it's not what we intend so if you know
how to fix that and have some some great
idea off the top of your head uh
consider
leaving a comment or working on the code
over on github and making a pull request
up to you how you want to do that
but yeah that's today's episode
and uh let me know what you think down
below
appreciate you guys a ton
you can uh support me by well there's
tons of links everywhere i'm not going
to say everything uh yeah there's
i just i just know that i really
appreciate you guys and i really really
love doing this is
this is great
hope you're enjoying it as much as i am
i'll see you the next one
peace out guys